tutti ragazzi e prevenuto questo video
sono file e oggi siamo tornati su blair
witch che sarebbe quel giochino tipo
lombardi giochiamo allo ragazzi nuovo
rimasti che c'era la porta bellissima e
ho sbloccato il lucchetto il mio
bellissimo amico bullet che sta fuori
per lui si caga addosso perché il mio
cane più sveglio di meglio nov io vado a
cercare la morte come faceva aprire le
cose ok modo non vendo che è una
bellissima spa ragazzi voi dentro non
c'è nulla se non questa macchina qua che
però praticamente c'è un metro suicidi
non ho capito cos'è ci devo fare niente
credo che ci debba ficcare il microfono
per chiedere aiuto però non solo non ce
l'ho e microfono bullet cioè il
microfono per caso fratello dove il cane
eccolo
cos'è che guardi che stavano andando mia
mamma mamma mia ragazzi i cani negli
horror mi fanno cagare sotto c'è sempre
qualcosa che non va quando puntano ma
questa ma della polizia ragazzi cos'è
successo
c'è scritto che devono connettere milan
channel 3 aspetta prendi la radio ok c'è
altre questo è stato parlando dello
scalo va bene va bene a proviamo ad
andare fuori dalla macchina puntano lì
quindi qualcuno mi esce da di sicuro va
bene e non posso aprire la macchina ma
porca vacca non c'ho la chiesa della
macchina va bene mi scusi vorrei aprirla
però non le chiavi tesoro di tornatore
chi a bravo che il cane ha trovato le
chiavi di quote sono almeno 26 bullet
vieni qua bravissimo madonna che cane
che casa non ci sta passando un tronco
in testa però tutto questo sembra vocale
va bene allora le chiavi della macchina
accendiamo le luci adesso mi spunta
satana lo sfoglio ragazzino potresti
investire l'ho visto che la macchina
nuova
teoricamente
potrebbe funzionare allora io sono
esperto di macchine quindi so
esattamente come si accende a posto
acceso le luci ragazzi ho messo tutte le
bobine a posto perché io elettricista
oltre che youtube se schiaccia il tasto
luci alla madonna che elettricista che
sono sono stato bravissimo
cioè ho fatto sfruttare il giorno sono
proprio un signore elettricista che dici
guidiamo non posso uscire
diamo sono riuscito a far diventare il
giorno ragazzi quando volete mi chiamate
faccio io teoricamente non so dove
stiamo andando però sono stato bravo
sono molto orgoglioso di me stesso devo
essere sincero e il mio cane prende il
sole non morire in acqua va bene che
bello ragazzi che bello sto veramente
andando a morire nella pratica bisogna
fare come questa mi dice ma allora sei
scemo faccio un cane che stupido ma
vieni qua cosa file attraverso fumi una
volta che bisognava dall'altra parte con
cui veramente geniale star bene secondo
me scolo della notte tra un secondo però
ok tanto qua il sole basso quando ci ha
voglia permesso meno male che tra
l'altro non hanno renderizzato anche gli
insetti perché sono mi avrebbe stiamo
solito ma veramente non ti disturba il
fatto che sia giorno
cosa che c'é qua sotto c'è del sangue lo
vedo ragazza nel sangue l'inter a
tripoli ma novak ridare alla mitica
automobile
ci si sposa ma che cos'è sta roba
il poliziotto questo è lo sceriffo ed
arrestare va beh almeno è capitato a lui
e non a me
comunque sia io consiglierei un dentista
ciao ragazzi comunque stiamo parlando
del fatto che c'è un killer nella
foresta che non saprai mai che in realtà
non è un togliere una specie di strega
strana però in tutto questo continuiamo
ad andare in giro per la foresta
tranquilli che come se niente quando non
ti va di prendere tipo un'arma qualcosa
non te frega niente
così sta roba alla cassetta magari si
vede cosa è successo tra cagando stato è
stata la strega è stato l'inizio che lo
accompagnava machista ma siete pazzi per
che centra un chi nella schiena perché
ti ha fatto impazzire la la blair witch
beni tutto questo sta vanga mamma mia
che schifo
la prendo sulle seguì inseguitori anche
perché può essere utile per difesa ho
supplicato lasciamo qua no perché qui i
protagonisti e gli horror sono
imprendibili ragazzi niente
bravo bravo canevari ti seguo bello però
sono contento che il mio ci stiano bene
l'importante l'amicizia comunque
poi dove passare la prima fiume esaro
turca sparito il fiume vabbè tanto è
diventato giorno da un momento all'altro
quindi non ti stupire i fan coesione ama
lui tratto si autogiustifica dico che è
successo
ragazzi non capitola sta succedendo city
fa il cane corri a che cosa succederà
perché c'è un elicottero e tutto questo
poi perché dovrebbe dargli problemi cioè
nel senso c'è un elicottero salvami no
questo è l'accordo che meglio borri di
gente venuta con la madonna il mio cane
madonna
c'è un sacco di itway side quando
spuntava la gente mi volesse sparare
ancora baican e vai
scatta
ricordo i corrieri dentro quelli intorno
tutto a posto permesso è quello che è
esattamente quello che gli volevo dire
io
detto questo però effettivamente stare
in una caverna brutta ski meno male che
non hanno fatto gli insetti pure quello
stavo per dire cosa potrebbe andare
peggio
siamo usciti non fu possibile sono
ancora una caverna si sta roba
distruggi fa abbiamo l'esempio
cosa questa roba sono i protagonisti del
film no scusate un attimo ma il mio cane
non è di non è spaventato da sti cosi
come il film copertura possibile come ha
fatto a passati qua la smetti di
aiutarmi nell'orecchio chi è non
militare nell'orecchio porco demonio
aiuto o benissimo
ora sì che so dove andare non so neanche
se sto andando giusto col demonio
schifoso
bye bye bye bye bye fa niente viaggio al
centro della terra diventata ragazzi non
so bene la storia che ci sta dietro
questa leggenda però so che il mio cane
non si trova quindi c'è un'uscita ecco
questo non è il mio cane in tutto questo
caso però c'è una ciotola ragazzi se mi
fate del male al cane vi ammazzo of
coraggio e rivas
mi sono guadagnato nelle mutande sport e
un altro con coniugate a hewson
livingston di giocarci gun
dietro al galles facevano il 16 amici
che significa mia immagine web
no e memoria
i wanna be insomma che schifo a lui sta
ricordando delle cose passate anno
costerà in scena il respiratore guarda
ora stacking questo vespri di monesi
from new york
beh comunque sono dei ricordi molto
belli da avere mi piace e come quando
sogno di limon armi con selena gomez poi
mi sveglio del sun che mi lega la faccia
uguale tesoro si è usciti la caverna ma
in tutto questo come mai io finisco in
punti dove non so come ci sono arrivato
c'è la caverna ri prima poco
completamente scomparsa pro è bello
perché puoi andare all'indietro
quindi io mi sono girato dalla parte
opposta dove dovrei andare e mi fa
andare quindi ancora più strana nostra
cosa perché c'è proprio tutto una
foresta scoprire sta cosa veramente
strana ragazza va bene sono contento di
essermi svegliato in questo punto c'è
proprio cent ornati qua ma di nuovo la
tenda cosa mi hai trovato amico mio
tutto sto casino per quei filoni
bulletta annusa lo al piede della tua
poesia va bene dai proviamo ad andare in
stampa cos'è sta roba da falegnameria
per diventi lui è meglio di google
google maps cioè di riciclo deve andare
lui due team non lo seguì ragazzi è
diventato call of duty del sud a
terminare ma vabbè
ma cos'ha scoperto ma per chi se la cava
male ma mi fanno male sicuri non mi devo
toccare ottimo bombardano e arrivano
nelle dorate trento miari un
meraviglioso fuori casa l'ultima vai vai
vai vai vai boulez file ed eccoci
attento moglie ci sono di bullet ci
sparano demonio
chi ha sparato
importante che non è un soggetto che mi
spara oggi madonna basta che fastidio ma
cos'è sta roba che sta succedendo ai
apporto dei modi prima mi stai
morsicandolo ma il mio cane di minozzi
che mi sa che è buono
chi l'ha visto
funzioni boarding
scavalca la donna non puoi guardarmi
dietro ad esso come centinario
parole meno
come arrivo come ciardi non ci arrivo
non ci arriverò mai
fatta a iannone arancione edizione che
non ama le o fastidio che vende bene e
devo arrivare fin laggiù ma non ci
arriva lo fa ai ragazzi dico ok
che sta succedendo che spiegatemi
supplico va bene bene a tutti i ragazzi
e benvenuti a questo non commenta di
call of duty o svengo ottimo ragazzi
presenti io passo di le puntate a
svenire a risvegliarmi nei lavori è
stato insegnante a un successo idilliaco
proprio meraviglioso fatto sei scemo
forte
devo andare veramente 18 a c'è ancora un
affare di anne hathaway ok
proviamo passati quasi mamma mia che
brutta roba
quindi ragazzi direi che possiamo
concludere qui l'episodio di blair witch
ci vediamo un prossimo so che è
interrotto se prendevi intorno per
ragazzi ma siete abituati ormai cosa mi
rompete le balle mettete e mi piace che
arriva proseguito io ve lo prometto
io li amo forse episodio iscritti al
canale spiaggia della campanellina e
ragazzi
[Musica]